il n'y a pas d'intérêt pour la france à
ne pas défendre le nucléaire c'est un
pur choix idéologique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le principe de base c'était d'avoir une
évaluation neutre technologiquement sans
billet et qu'ils puissent se fonder sur
un critère fondamental qui est les
émissions de carbone mais de manière
vraiment scandaleuse par pure idéologie
et bien on a écarté le nucléaire de
cette taxonomie parce que certains pays
sont résolument hostiles au nucléaire
l'autriche par exemple ou le luxembourg
et la france qui repose beaucoup pour
son mix énergétique sur cette
électricité est bien n'a pas su n'a pas
voulu défendre cet atout que représente
le nucléaire pour la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
[Musique]
le propre du nucléaire c'est que c'est
une énergie décarbonée une énergie qui
n'est pas intermittentes qui est
pilotable mais c'est aussi une énergie
qui est peu cher parce que cette énergie
elle est produite par des centrales le
parc nucléaire français est aujourd'hui
amortissent lui dire qu'aujourd'hui les
investissements qui ont été faits pour
le construire
ils sont derrière nous on essaie
d'ailleurs un atout pour les ménages
évidemment mais c'est aussi un des
derniers atouts de l'industrie française
parce que l'industrie consomme beaucoup
d'électricité et qu'aujourd'hui le choix
d'un industriel pour s'implanter dans un
pays il est lié en particulier à ce
facteur du prix et la disponibilité de
l'électricité
[Musique]
les énergies renouvelables elles ont une
particularité c'est qu'elles ne sont pas
pilotable dans les périodes hivernales
quand il ya ni vent ni lumière
eh bien on court le risque en fait de se
trouver en situation de pénurie c'est ce
qui a été vécu par la france le 8
janvier dernier
rte avait signalé qu'on glisse qu'est le
black out et avait demandé aux français
de réduire leur consommation
d'électricité
on est passé pas loin de cette situation
compliquée mais on l'a fait en achetant
de l'électricité du coup à nos voisins
en particulier aux allemands qui la
produisent encore avec des centrales à
charbon
ironie de l'histoire il n'ya pas
d'intérêt pour la france à ne pas
défendre le nucléaire c'est un pur choix
idéologique qui a commencé avec françois
hollande françois hollande voulait
garantir que les verts allaient
continuer de soutenir et pour pouvoir
sauver la gauche plurielle
il a accepté de brader le nucléaire nous
avons fermer fessenheim
parce que c'était l'objet d'une
négociation interne à la gauche
plurielle entre hollande et les verts
emmanuel macron a poursuivi dans cette
voie il aurait pu ne pas fermer
fessenheim et gemma qu'on veut sans
aucun doute apparaître comme un
président vert qui sert la cause de
l'écologie et pour des raisons qui sont
liées à leur histoire politique les
écologistes en france en particulier ce
n'est pas le cas partout sont résolument
anti nucléaire